my friend and I would say colleague to
some extent she'll be on the show again
in a couple weeks uh Megan Kelly has
just announced that she now has an
autoimmune issue which her doctor told
her is likely because of getting the
coveted vaccine
I regret getting the vaccine even though
I'm a 52 year old woman because I don't
think I needed it I think I would have
been fine I've got covered many times
and I it was well passed when the
vaccine was doing what it was supposed
to be doing
um and then for the first time I tested
positive for an autoimmune issue at my
annual physical and I asked I went to
the best rheumatologist in New York and
I asked her do you think this could have
to do with the fact that I got the damn
booster and then got covered within
three weeks and she said yes yes I
wasn't the only one she'd seen all right
so now does that make Megyn Kelly a
conspiracy theorist does it make her a
crazy person or a tin foil hat wearer or
any of that stuff she got a vaccine that
she kind of got coerced into as she's
saying like she didn't really feel like
she needed it she had already she did it
post finding out it was already a little
shady in the first place and now she has
this autoimmune issue I don't know
anything beyond that related to her
health but I certainly hope that but
she's okay but we all know people like
that
I know a guy in his early 20s who never
had heart issues who now has heart
issues I know two or three people that
are having shingles related things and
balancing related things and someone
having Vision related things all
post-vacs now are they all definitely
connected to vacs I don't know I don't
know but we were sold a lie on this
stuff and why do you think so many
people fell for it because we get hit
constantly every day with this endless
propaganda machine whether it is either
propaganda as it relates to war which
again I'm going to bring this whole
thing around I promise you or whether
it's vaccines or climate change or
anything else and and it happens so fast
now because of social media we don't
even notice the hypocrisy
foreign